>> Trace: WINDS AREN’T HELPING.
JANICE DEAN LIVE IN THE WEATHER
CENTER.
THANK YOU.
>> WHAT WAS PRESIDENT XI SAYING
YESTERDAY?
>> President Trump: WE WERE
TALKING MOSTLY ABOUT THE VIRUS
AND I THINK HE WILL HAVE IT IN
GOOD SHAPE.
IT IS A VERY TRICKY SITUATION.
IT GOES THROUGH AIR, BOB,
THAT’S ALWAYS TOUGHER THAN THE
TOUCH.
THE TOUCH, YOU JUST BREATHE THE
AIR AND THAT’S HOW IT IS PASSED.
THAT’S A VERY TRICKY ONE.
A VERY DELICATE ONE.
IT IS ALSO MORE DEADLY THAN
YOUR -- EVEN YOUR STRENUOUS
FLUS.
PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE WE LOSE
25,000, 30,000 PEOPLE A YEAR
HERE.
WHO WOULD EVER THINK THAT?
THAT’S PRETTY AMAZING.
I SAY WELL -- THIS IS MORE
DEADLY.
THIS IS 5% VERSUS 1% AND LESS
THAN 1%.
THIS IS DEADLY STUFF.
>> Sandra: PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKING TO BOB WOODWARD ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC IN EARLY FEBRUARY
SAYING THAT HE KNEW THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS WAS DEADLY BUT
WANTED TO DOWNPLAY IT.
JOE BIDEN AND OTHER DEMOCRATS
JUMPING ON THAT NEWS.
THE PRESIDENT HIT BACK
YESTERDAY CALLING WOODWARD’S
NEW BOOK A POLITICAL HIT JOB.
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE IS
TODAY’S HEADLINER AND JOINS US
NOW.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, GOOD
MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Sandra: THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS DEFENSE OF THE AUDIO TAPES
HAS BASICALLY SAID THIS WAS A
STRATEGY ON HIS PART TO PREVENT
PANIC, TO BRING CALM TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO IF IT WAS A STRATEGY, IS IT
ONE THAT YOU KNEW OF, MR. VICE
PRESIDENT?
>> WHAT I SAW FIRST-HAND FROM
THAT DAY IN JANUARY IN THE OVAL
OFFICE WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
TOOK THE UNPRECEDENTED STEP OF
SUSPENDING ALL TRAVEL FROM
CHINA, DECLARING A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY IS THAT THIS
PRESIDENT PUT THE HEALTH OF
AMERICA FIRST FROM DAY ONE.
BUT HE ALSO WANTED TO REASSURE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ALL ALONG
THE WAY.
THERE IS THAT OLD SAYING FROM
WORLD WAR II IN GREAT BRITAIN
THAT KEEP CALM, CARRY ON, AND
THAT WAS THE PRESIDENTIAL
LEADERSHIP THAT I SAW.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FACT
THAT JOE BIDEN, DEMOCRATS AND
EVEN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION CRITICIZED THE
PRESIDENT’S DECISION TO SUSPEND
ALL TRAVEL FROM CHINA, IT TOOK
PLACE A WEEK BEFORE THAT AUDIO
CLIP THAT YOU JUST PLAYED.
AND WHEN YOU SEE THAT IT WAS IN
MARCH, THE OTHER AUDIO CLIP
THAT IS GETTING A LOT OF
COVERAGE IS FROM MARCH 19th
WHERE THE PRESIDENT SPOKE ABOUT
HIS DESIRE TO CREATE A TONE TO
PREVENT PANIC.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT MADE THAT COMMENT
FOUR DAYS AFTER WE SHUT DOWN
THE ENTIRE AMERICAN ECONOMY TO
PUT THE HEALTH OF AMERICA FIRST.
AND SO LOOK, FROM THE MOMENT HE
TASKED ME TO LEAD THE WHITE
HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE,
THE PRESIDENT MADE IT CLEAR HE
WANTED US TO DEPLOY THE FULL
RESOURCES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, A WHOLE OF AMERICA
APPROACH, AND THE PROGRESS THAT
WE HAVE MADE I BELIEVE IS
LITERALLY SAVED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS IF NOT MILLIONS OF
LIVES.
BUT ALL ALONG THE WAY WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAW WAS A
PRESIDENT WHO WAS PROJECTING
THE KIND OF LEADERSHIP, THE
KIND OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND ALL OF OUR
HEALTHCARE EXPERTS AND DOCTORS
AND NURSES THAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT FROM A PRESIDENT IN A
CHALLENGING TIME LIKE THIS.
>> Sandra: TO YOUR POINT OUR
PRODUCERS PUT TOGETHER SOME OF
THOSE VARIOUS MOMENTS THAT
FOLLOWED THESE AUDIO TAPES OF
THE PRESIDENT PUTTING OUT THIS
CALM TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS
THE PANDEMIC WAS REALLY SETTING
IN.
LISTEN.
>> President Trump: I THINK IT
WILL ALL WORK OUT FINE.
ROUGH STUFF, I TELL YOU ROUGH,
ROUGH STUFF BUT I THINK IT WILL
WORK OUT.
PEOPLE HAVE TO REMAIN CALM.
I WANT TO KEEP THE COUNTRY CALM.
I DON’T WANT PANIC IN THE
COUNTRY.
I COULD CAUSE PANIC MUCH BETTER
THAN EVEN YOU.
>> Sandra: MR. VICE PRESIDENT
YOU REWIND TO FEBRUARY 7 AND
HEAR HIM ON THE TAPE SAYING
IT’S DEADLY STUFF.
MORE DEADLY THAN YOUR STRENUOUS
FLU AND TALKING ABOUT HOW
CONTAGIOUS THIS VIRUS IS
SPREADING THROUGH AIR.
IN THE WEEKS THAT FOLLOWED
PUBLICLY AT A NEW HAMPSHIRE
RALLY TELLING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IT IS GOING TO BE FINE.
FEBRUARY 26 THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE MEETING
SAYING THAT IT’S POSSIBLE THE
CASE NUMBER WILL GO TO ZERO.
COMPARING IT TO THE FLU TWICE.
HE TALKED ABOUT CALM BUT HE
ALSO TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IT IS GOING TO GO AWAY.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S STRATEGY TO IN YOUR
WORDS AND THE PRESIDENT’S TO
BRING THIS CALM, DID HE HARM
THE ABILITY TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF THIS VIRUS BY NOT WARNING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT HE
KNEW WERE THE DANGERS OF IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT, SANDRA.
AGAIN, I WANT TO GO BACK.
JOE BIDEN, THE DEMOCRATS, AND
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
CRITICIZED THE PRESIDENT’S
DECISION TO SUSPEND ALL TRAVEL
FROM CHINA.
IN EARLY FEBRUARY WE WERE
HEARING TELL ABOUT THIS
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS THAT WAS
SPREADING ACROSS WUHAN.
THE PRESIDENT PUT THE HEALTH OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST.
IN THAT FIRST WEEK OF FEBRUARY
WE STARTED WORK ON A VACCINE.
IN SIX SHORT WEEKS WE ALREADY
WERE IN CLINICAL TRIALS FOR A
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE’RE WELL ON OUR
WAY TO HAVING A CORONAVIRUS
VACCINE IN RECORD TIME BEFORE
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
ALL ALONG THE WAY, ASSESSING
SUPPLIES, ASSESSING LOGISTICS,
AND WHEN WE CAME TO THAT MOMENT
ON MARCH 15th, THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED THAT FIRST 15 DAYS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD, IT WOULD
BECOME 45 DAYS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD.
ALL ALONG THE WAY THE
PRESIDENT’S MANDATE WAS THAT WE
WOULD SPARE NO EXPENSE, WE
WOULD PUT THE HEALTH OF AMERICA
FIRST DESPITE THE CRITICISM
THAT HE ENDURED.
YOU NEED TO REMEMBER, TOO,
SANDRA, THAT ON THE LAST DAY OF
FEBRUARY THERE WERE ROUGHLY 15
DOMESTIC CASES OF CORONAVIRUS
IN AMERICA.
AND A MONTH EARLIER THE
PRESIDENT SUSPENDED ALL TRAVEL
FROM CHINA UNDER A HAILSTORM OF
CRITICISM FROM JOE BIDEN AND
THE LEFT.
TWO WEEKS LATER WE WOULD
SUSPEND ESSENTIALLY MUCH OF THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY TO PUT THE
HEALTH OF OUR COUNTRY FIRST.
WE REINVENTED TESTING.
NOW WE’RE DOING MORE THAN
800,000 TESTS A DAY.
WE SAW TO THE DISTRIBUTION AND
THE MANUFACTURE OF HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF SUPPLIES OF PPE AND
NEW MEDICINES.
I COULDN’T BE MORE PROUD OF THE
RESPONSE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
MORE PROUD OF THE RESPONSE OF
HEALTH OFFICIALS IN EVERY
AGENCY OF GOVERNMENT, STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I COULDN’T BE MORE PROUD OF THE
STRONG, STEADY LEADERSHIP THAT
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP BROUGHT
TO THIS CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC
FROM DAY ONE.
>> Sandra: I SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT DR. FAUCI WAS INTERVIEWED
AFTER THE REVELATION OF THESE
TAPES AND HE SAID HE DIDN’T SEE
A DISPARITY ON WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS TELLING HIM AND
WHAT HE WAS TELLING THE PUBLIC
AND WHAT HE WAS DOING, MR. VICE
PRESIDENT.
BUT --
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT AND LET
ME HELP YOU WITH THAT.
I’VE WORKED WITH DR. FAUCI
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY IN THIS
AND ALL OF OUR HEALTH EXPERTS.
WHEN DR. FAUCI SAID YESTERDAY
THAT EVERYTHING THAT OUR HEALTH
EXPERTS TOLD THE PRESIDENT IN
THE OVAL OFFICE HE WENT OUT AND
TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO I BELIEVE WHAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS SPEAKING ABOUT WITH BOB
WOODWARD ON MARCH 19th WAS JUST
THE TONE THAT HE WAS PROJECTING.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO
BELIEVES THAT A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IN SUCH
MOMENTS NEEDS TO PROJECT
STRENGTH.
YOU CAN’T PROJECT WEAKNESS.
>> Sandra: THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE, MR. VICE PRESIDENT.
>> THAT WE WILL TOGETHER GET
THROUGH THIS.
HIS TONE WAS ONE OF PROJECTING
CALM AND CONFIDENCE.
I HEARD HIM AT THAT PODIUM AND
IN EVERY SETTING, WE GAVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE FACTS AND I
LITERALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT’S DECISION TO SUSPEND
TRAVEL TO CHINA, THE LARGEST
MOBILIZATION SINCE WORLD WAR II
AND ASKING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO SHUT DOWN OUR ECONOMY FOUR
45 DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD TO
SAVE LIVES IS EXACTLY THE KIND
OF PRESIDENTIAL LEADERSHIP THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HOPE AND
PRAY FOR IN TIMES LIKE TH.
>> Sandra: WHAT IS BEING
DEBATED WHILE WE ALL TAKE IN
THESE AUDIO TAPES IS WHETHER IT
WAS MISINFORMATION TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT THE PRESIDENT
KNEW HOW DEADLY IT WAS.
MORE DEADLY THAN A STRENUOUS
FLU AND TO COMPARE IT TO THE
FLU.
ROBERT O’BRIEN, NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR CONFIRMED IN
LATE JANUARY AT AN INTELLIGENCE
BRIEFING WARNED THE PRESIDENT
THIS WOULD BE THE BIGGEST
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT THAT
HE WOULD FACE DURING HIS
PRESIDENCY.
WERE YOU PRIVY TO THAT SAME
INFORMATION THAT DAY?
DID YOU RECEIVE THAT BRIEFING,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT?
>> Sandra:
>> I WAS IN THE OVAL OFFICE THE
DAY THE TEAM BRIEFED THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT WHAT WE
PERCEIVED WAS HAPPENING IN
CHINA.
REMEMBER, THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION FAILED US, CHINA
WAS NOT FORTHCOMING WITH THE
UNITED STATES ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING THERE.
BUT THE TEAM CAME IN AND LAID
THE FACTS AS WE KNEW THEM ON
THE TABLE TO THE PRESIDENT AND
AGAIN, I HAVE TO TELL YOU, TO
SEE THE PRESIDENT SIT BEHIND
THE RESOLUTE DESK IN THE OVAL
OFFICE AND DO WHAT NO AMERICA
PRESIDENT HAD EVER DONE.
IT WAS SUSPEND ALL TRAVEL FROM
CHINA.
TO ME IT WAS AN HISTORIC
EXAMPLE OF PRESIDENTIAL
LEADERSHIP.
IT SAVED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
IF NOT MILLIONS OF LIVES.
BUT THE TRUTH IS WE WERE
LEARNING ALL ALONG THE WAY.
I MEAN ON THIS NETWORK, ON
OTHER NETWORKS YOU HAD HEALTH
EXPERTS.
OUR OWN HEALTH EXPERTS WERE NOT
YET CONVINCED ABOUT THE LEVEL
OF CONTAGION OR HOW SERIOUS IT
WAS.
I THINK DR. FAUCI OFTEN SPEAKS
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE FOG OF WAR
AND WHEN I STEPPED INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCE LEADERSHIP AT THE END OF
FEBRUARY, AGAIN WE ONLY HAD 15
CASES OF CORONAVIRUS DOMESTIC
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE FIRST CASE OF COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION ALSO HAPPENED AT
THE VERY END OF FEBRUARY.
SO LOOK, YOU KNOW, HINDSIGHT IS
2020, RECRIMINATIONS.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
COMMUNICATING, I BELIEVE WHAT
YOU HEAR IN THAT FEBRUARY TAPE
WAS THE SERIOUSNESS WITH WHICH
HE TOOK THIS FROM DAY ONE AND
AGAIN, I THINK YOUR VIEWERS
DESERVE TO KNOW THAT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT MADE THE COMMENT
ABOUT DOWN PLAYING ON MARCH
19th, THAT WAS FOUR DAYS AFTER
THIS PRESIDENT ORDERED US TO
SHUT DOWN THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
ECONOMY TO PUT THE HEALTH OF
AMERICA FIRST.
>> Sandra: ON THAT NOTE, HE DID
SPEAK TO BOB WOODWARD IN 18
DIFFERENT INTERVIEWS FOR NINE
HOURS.
THE PRESIDENT’S CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS ON FOX NEWS LAST
NIGHT IS NOT SOMETHING HE WOULD
HAVE RECOMMENDED WAS HE IN THE
ROLE AT THAT TIME.
DID YOU KNOW HE WAS TALKING TO
BOB WOODWARD 18 DIFFERENT TIMES
FOR NINE HOURS?
>> I RAN INTO BOB WOODWARD ONCE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
I DON’T KNOW THERE HAS EVER
BEEN A MORE ACCESSIBLE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THAN PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sandra: WAS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
>> WALKING TO THE AIRPLANE,
WALKING TO THE HELICOPTER,
PRESS BRIEFINGS.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
STRAIGHT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WAY HE HAS
LED THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC,
THAT’S ALSO BEEN TRUE.
HONESTLY, TONY FAUCI PUT IT SO
WELL YESTERDAY WHEN HE SAID
EVERYTHING THAT OUR HEALTH
EXPERTS TOLD THE PRESIDENT IN
THE OVAL OFFICE HE TOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, OKAY?
AND IT’S IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT’S WHAT I SAW AS WELL.
I ACTUALLY DIDN’T SENSE THE
PRESIDENT WAS DOWN PLAYING
ANYTHING.
WE WERE GIVING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE FACTS AS WE KNEW
THEM, AS WE LEARNED THEM EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
INCREDIBLE DOCTORS AND NURSES,
HEALTH OFFICIALS IN STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND ALL
ACROSS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RESPONDED WITH INCREDIBLE
PROFESSIONALISM.
BUT IT IS SO IMPORTANT IN
MOMENTS LIKE THIS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
PROJECT CONFIDENCE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WERE
DEPLOYING THE FULL RESOURCES OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, CALLING
FORTH THE FULL POWER OF THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY TO MEET THIS
MOMENT.
AND I PROMISE YOU, SANDRA, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY UNTIL WE HAVE A
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE AND WE PUT
THIS PANDEMIC IN THE PAST ONCE
AND FOR ALL.
>> Sandra: WE HAVE A LOT MORE
TO GET TO.
IF I COULD ASK YOU ABOUT THE
WILDFIRES RAGING ON THE WEST
COAST.
THREE STATES AFFECTED.
SEEING SEVEN DEATHS NOW, ONE
INVOLVING A SMALL CHILD.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US AS BEING
DONE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL NOW
TO STEP IN AND HELP AS THESE
FIRES ARE STILL RAGING?
>> WE’RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH GOVERNORS IN STATES THAT
ARE AFFECTED.
I THINK WHEN GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM SUBMITTED A DISASTER
DECLARATION PRESIDENT TRUMP
APPROVED THAT IN ROUGHLY 24
HOURS.
WE’VE ISSUED 22 SEPARATE
FEDERAL FIRE SUPPORT GRANTS AND
WE’VE ALREADY GOT RESOURCES BY
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
ARE FLOWING TO IMPACTED
FAMILIES.
LOOK, MY DAUGHTER AND
SON-IN-LAW LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO ALL OF
THOSE THAT ARE ENDURING OR
THREATENED BY THESE FIRES.
I WANT TO ASSURE EVERYONE THAT
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE THOSE
COURAGEOUS FIREFIGHTERS THAT
HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES HAVE
THE FULL SUPPORT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WE MAKE OUR WAY
THROUGH THESE FIRES, BUT ALSO
AS WE MAKE OUR WAY THROUGH WHAT
IS JUST ACTUALLY THE BEGINNING
OF THE FIRE SEASON OUT WEST.
>> Sandra: AMAZING TO SEE THE
ORANGE SKIES OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND SUCH AN ENORMOUS TASK FOR
THOSE ON THE GROUND FIGHTING
THE FLAMES.
I WANT TO MOVE ON TO YOU ON THE
GROUND IN PENNSYLVANIA
YESTERDAY, MR. VICE PRESIDENT.
PENNSYLVANIA A KEY STATE IN THE
UPCOMING ELECTION.
A STATE THE PRESIDENT CARRIED
IN 2016.
HE IS BEHIND IN THE REAL CLEAR
POLITICS AVERAGE OF POLLS IN
THAT STATE RIGHT NOW.
OBVIOUSLY YOU WERE THERE ON THE
GROUND TRYING TO SWAY VOTERS
WITH YOUR -- YOURS AND THE
PRESIDENT’S LAW AND ORDER
MESSAGE.
MESSAGE ON THE ECONOMY.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING AS YOU WORK
YOUR WAY TOWARDS YOUR BIG
DEBATE OCTOBER 7th WITH KAMALA
HARRIS?
WHAT IS THE STRATEGY TO WIN
OVER VOTERS IN A STATE LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA?
>> WE’RE GOING TO GO OUT AND
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS KEPT MORE
PROMISES THAN HE MADE TO THE
PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
HE SAID WE ARE GOING TO REBUILD
OUR MILITARY.
WE’LL REVIVE THE ECONOMY WITH
LESS TAXES, LESS REGULATION,
MORE FREE AND FAIR TRADE, AND
MORE AMERICAN ENERGY.
WE’LL STAND BY OUR MOST
CHERISHED VALUES INCLUDING THE
RIGHT TO LIFE.
YESTERDAY IN PENNSYLVANIA WE
CELEBRATED THIS PRESIDENT’S
NOMINATION OF MORE THAN 200
STRONG CONSERVATIVES TO OUR
FEDERAL COURTS INCLUDING TWO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S STRONG STAND
FOR THE RIGHT TO LIFE WHICH
RESONATES WITH PEOPLE ACROSS
THE HEARTLAND INCLUDING
PENNSYLVANIA.
BUT THE MESSAGE THAT I DROVE
HOME YESTERDAY LITERALLY
STANDING AT A DRILLING SITE IN
PENNSYLVANIA PRESIDENT TRUMP
PROMISED WE WOULD UNLEASH
AMERICAN ENERGY.
WE’VE DONE JUST THAT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 70 YEARS
WE’RE A NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
BUT JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
ACTUALLY HAVE TALKED ABOUT
ABOLISHING FOSSIL FUELS.
I KNOW JOE BIDEN NOW HE WENT TO
PITTSBURGH AND SAID HE IS NOT
BANNING FRACKING, BUT THAT’S AT
ODDS WITH EVERYTHING THAT HE
HAS SAID FOR THE LAST YEAR.
HE TOLD ONE SUPPORTER I
GUARANTEE -- I GUARANTEE THAT
WE WILL ABOLISH FOSSIL FUELS.
HE SAID IN A DEBATE THAT EVEN
IF IT COSTS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN JOBS,
THAT THERE WOULD BE NO PLACE
FOR FRACKING OR FOSSIL FUELS IN
HIS ADMINISTRATION.
BASED ON THE ENTHUSIASM I SAW
ON THAT PARTICULARLY HOT DAY
YESTERDAY IN FREEDOM,
PENNSYLVANIA IS THAT PEOPLE OF
PENNSYLVANIA ARE GETTING THE
MESSAGE.
THEY KNOW IT.
THEY VOTED FOR A PRESIDENT WHO
WAS COMMITTED TO A STRONG
MILITARY, TO LAW AND ORDER AT
HOME, TO A GROWING ECONOMY, TO
MORE AMERICAN ENERGY, TO
TRADITIONAL VALUES, AND THEY
KNOW THE CHOICE IN THIS
ELECTION COULD NOT BE MORE
CLEAR.
I THINK PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA
WILL VOTE FOR FOUR MORE YEARS
FOR PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Sandra: MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
WE’RE OUT OF TIME.
IT WAS GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE